even with this neural link thing there
might be a possibility where he gets
shut down and then Google and alphabet
and the Pentagon come in and then
they're like we got the newer microchip
it's a lot better and there's no one
that's going to stop us because we're
going to have the Monopoly on this as we
just stopped Elon Musk so there's
there's an argument here that I've been
going back and forth on uh that I've
been talking about for a very long time
is that Elon Musk has a lot of power and
a lot of responsibility
um and when it comes to that power and
responsibility we want to specifically
know if he's going to be using that
power and responsibility in a good way
or in a bad way because that's a lot of
power for one individual to have is he
doing it so these new powers this new
technology is going to be used for the
greater good or is that greater good
just going to ruin him and destroy him
because it's too much power for one
single person to have that's a question
that I've been going back and forth on I
don't know what do you think well hold
on I just figured it out I'm just gonna
hate everyone because Elon Musk I mean
what if he's like the Pied Piper acting
like we're we you know he's doing all
this good for us I got free speech for
you right here and then basically
there's a box that says free speech and
there's a stick and everybody's running
over doing he's going to pull that stick
and the box is going to come down you
know what I mean that is what's
happening in my opinion and I'm gonna
tell you why I've been in this movement
for a while two years ago conservatives
would have never defended this chip at
all I remember I used to talk about it
now if you look though if you talk about
the Elon Musk chip on Twitter
conservatives will defend it now it's
like yo yo we actually love it and I
don't think he can use it for good
because he's a Godless Soul right and he
already told you why he's doing it it's
not for the greater good he said we
can't win against AI so we need to
combine with AI he told you this on The
Joe Rogan interview clear-cut well AI is
going to be the next people don't
understand the significance of
artificial intelligence uh Vladimir
Putin has called it the next nuclear
weapon and the country that develops it
first will have uh ultimate uh potential
to have total world to domination with
it so when it comes to this power who
would you rather have this latest
technology this is the question that I
think maybe uh some uh Elon Musk Fanboys
are asking themselves do you want China
to have that power do you want alphabet
to have that power or Google uh the
Pentagon or do you want Elon Musk who is
representing the larger ideas of Free
Speech but at the same time if you're
doing that you shouldn't be wearing a
Satan costume that's worth uh nine
thousand dollars and still have it as
your main profile picture on Twitter and
he changed his location to hell but my
issue did he really know yeah I didn't
see that yeah he tried to location on
Twitter to hell but he changed it back
but my question is if Elon Musk does
have the power who's to say that he's
who's to say that Google won't create a
better version while he has it yeah you
know what I'm saying he builds it they
take it over and hijack the technology
for their own personal benefit but but
the argument is they're building the
technology anyway it's going to be here
anyway uh who's going to be navigating
it is the is the kind of conversation
that I think is being had here he has
said like he's tried talking to Congress
about the dangers of AI while also
you know creating things that I think
are wildly dangerous that sever you from
humanity and God and I think the chip is
bad
um and I don't agree with it and then I
like obviously I like what he's doing
with Twitter but even with that he's
kind of leading with subjectivity you
know he's basing his emotions on Alex
Jones or yay like on his own personal
feelings and I'm just like you I think
you should be able to say whatever you
want of course but at least he's being
honest about it
you won't see Google doing that you
don't have the alphabet and that's why
he's better than the alphabet people but
it was like a child right yeah
absolutely
he said he said he bad Kanye because of
inciting violence yeah it made me want
to punch Kanye so that's why I ban him
yeah he's like who's being violent now
you know what I'm saying come on I had
this uh this Vision we were it was like
one day we were doing the after show and
I had this idea for like a TV show and
it's basically I'll try and give you the
quick synopsis there's one city left on
Earth the entire planet is basically
wiped out there's just like abandoned
cities everywhere and there's it's it's
like 20 80 or something there's a few
million people living in this big city
it's the last City and they have like
scouting missions going out and
Gathering old technology and stuff when
one day they come across these creepy
slim looking humanoid creatures with
chrome helmets who just like blast them
with an energy wave and kill their
scouting party but one guy escapes the
long story short of it is
the people don't understand why the
world ended the news records just ceases
they're looking at old data centers and
they're like trying to go online and
find records and newspapers and around
like you know a certain period or maybe
it's like 21 something a certain period
like in 2070s news just starts to slowly
stop but there's no definitive end
there's no warning there's no war just
one day they're like the record just
slowly trickles off and stops
so the general idea is what would happen
if neurolink became the thing today
and everyone started using it the
conversation would be happening on
neuralink more and more and more and if
you weren't using it you would have no
access to the latest news you wouldn't
be in the network
so then a hundred years later the people
who refused call it you know Godless or
evil or satanic or whatever they're like
we don't know what happened just one day
like everybody was gone we can't like
you know if you're like third or fourth
generation down you're like the people
all left we don't know where they went
there's no records of history but then
those creepy creatures I mentioned are
the people who are living in pods
underground wired in the neural link who
come up periodically to collect
resources so that was that was my idea
kind of like it's basically like a
division of what may happen that's like
the evolved version of people deleting
friends off you know different social
media platforms you know you you enter
these little Bubbles and then when you
see them again like two years have
passed and politics have passed and they
have all these new ideas they look like
creatures to you everything's different
no I just mean like
the people who use neuralink will become
will be having a conversation you won't
be able to see or hear because you don't
have norling give that 100 years and
what's that going to be it's going to be
like two different species just not
right it will be Eli must say it he
wants everybody to have access to any
information with knurling that's what he
said he wanted from it out of his own
mouth so what you're saying is like I
mean you might call it a Daydream or
something but that sounds like what 50
years in my opinion something like that
well who knows what how fast technology
is advancing and he also said he could
have a microchip already in his brain
and no one would be able to even know
that he has it so that's what he said
publicly as well I think he does
I would love to talk to him about
transhumanism artificial intelligence I
think he knows a lot more than he's
letting on to but his words warning
people about AI I think is very
important that we should be paying
attention it is have you guys have you
guys seen that Viral chat GPT thing the
open AI released this chat bot man it's
crazy
homework is gone there's no such thing
as homework anymore so if you're a
teacher and you tell a kid right write
an essay about you know the pilgrims
landing and what happened you open up
chat GPT and you say write an essay
about the pilgrims Landing in Plymouth
Rock and it will generate a unique essay
boom just like that and then you click
print and you go here you go all done
so this this this chat AI somebody did
something funny where they were like uh
they were like write a joke about George
Floyd in the style of Jerry Seinfeld and
it was just really really bad they were
like well you know the funny thing is
they said it wasn't funny but I think it
was because they were awoke person they
didn't find it funny because it it
wasn't funny in the way you'd expect a
joke to be funny but it was kind of
funny this robot trying to mock the
death like it was it's like dark it's
like black humor like very brutal but uh
this AI stuff someone put the political
typology quiz to it like they asked
these questions and the AI was a liberal
one degree to the right of a progressive
leftist so like actually kind of far
left the AIS that are all being trained
are being trained by a censored far left
internet so the future if conservatives
resist all of this and the left accepts
all of this it's gonna be like some
weird sci-fi movie where you got like
some dude in camo Gear with like black
paint under his eyes like an AR fighting
some weird dude flying through the air
shooting lasers at him me I'm Rambo man
let's get it I'm ready I like I like the
war Bryson versus Robocop you feel me
let's get it guaranteed but I think I
think people are gonna adopt you know
earlier on saying like who's going to
want to get a chip in their brain uh I
think you made it you know a good point
when you're talking about the lockdowns
and how everyone just marches along and
now I'm just like yep you know what it's
just gonna happen I'm gonna go I I agree
with that still but I also want to say
like and this might be like a con
contact high from the positivity from
Yen this weekend but like
in California every driver I had I had
long conversations with all of them they
were all anti-lockdown anti-like the
government overreach and I was shocked
you know because it really blew my brain
you know because the news I've never
been out there and they make you think
it's a wasteland I think a lot of places
are Wasteland in this country right now
after the last two years but they were
so positive and they saw like a hope
after learning like they saw the
government destroy so many things so
like I did take away some positivity
from those you know it's a handful of
conversations but I didn't expect to
have those so maybe maybe there's a
little bit of Hope out there well I
think most people are still like
conservatives if there's a fair Battle
of ideas conservatives always win you
can see that with Andrew Tate right they
had the band entertain they became the
most popular person in the world fairly
fairly quickly to the point where he
went against the Hassan Packers who
against all these people and he won the
Battle of ideas to the point to where
they had to say you're out of here so if
there's a fair Battle of ideas we still
win because we have so so here's the
crazy thing why if the ideas they have
lose
why do they want them to be maintained
they like power yeah no I get that but
why not just if you why not just adopt
the good idea and maintain power then
they don't think there's a good well I
mean there's gonna be friction and
Humanity that's as natural as Humanity
as as eating and drinking water right it
doesn't has to be friction so I think
they I mean they they want their ideas
to win I'm be honest right this might
sound crazy I think a lot of these kids
were pit on these pills when they were
younger and they grow up and they don't
understand they they don't understand no
I was at a Matt lost rally and I saw a
guy with green hair spit on a a guy that
was on our side and I'm like
do you know what happened where I'm from
you spit on somebody
oh yeah like but but I don't think
people understand they get paid on these
pills these pills literally tell you
they make you crazy right and I don't
think they can that's why they can't
function somebody disagrees with them
right right that's why they can't just
function so I think these are the people
in charge of Twitter not anymore in
charge of social media in charge of
everything and and what's gonna happen
is there's going to be this ad campaign
from neuralink where it's like only
racists don't get me a link and they're
gonna go I'm not a racist plug me in
baby just they're gonna have like a
thing that's gonna go into your spinal
literally you could be an oppressed
minority in the AI digital system if you
get the brain chip I see that coming
like he could be Native American
Elizabeth Warren signing up right now
like yes yes I mean to live my life and
then you won't be able to buy or sale
with it I couldn't see I couldn't see
the the shift from Elon Musk you know
neural link playing woke trying to be
able to sign up that's why I'm like is
he this Pied Piper who's trying to
convince all these people on the right
think about it this way what group of
people will reject neuralink outright
okay it's conservatives they we they go
on shows and they'll outright say like
I'm never getting that I mean you're
saying it right now so Elon Musk knows I
don't need the one over the left they're
gonna do it they're gonna do whatever
they're told to do the right is gonna
resist I need to win them over and then
he's gonna come he'll come out and I
don't know exactly what he'll do to try
and convince people to get norlink he'll
say something like we've had people
defending it and and Fair Point people
who are paralyzed and stuff you know
that really can't help them but I
wouldn't be surprised if he comes out
and he's like you know we're going to
have absolute free speech and we're
going to bypass the system and push back
and boot out the FBI deep State and
we're gonna do it on your link we're
going to progress ourselves out of
existence like that's what's happening
and uh I don't like that future
I think it's it's a very Bleak future
one one generation at a time slowly more
and more machine yeah and then in a
thousand years there's no humans there's
just weird robots flying around making
more of themselves but isn't that the
way they convince people because all you
have to do in the media deserts all the
time and it left out that they're the
best at it you control people with
emotions right if somebody's emotionally
attached to something you you have a
better chance of convincing them so if
neuralink like you already said oh can
help somebody in a wheelchair or a Elon
Musk that can help you if you're blind
it can help you if you have Alzheimer's
you know what I'm saying everybody knows
somebody in their family with these
things you know what I'm saying so if
they pull your emotional strings I think
a lot of people will start getting it
for their family and then next week you
know nothing that was normalizing
everybody not just that but if you're
depressed if you're anxious which a lot
of people are because of how the diet
has been essentially destroyed here in
the United States which more and more
people are becoming as they're becoming
dependent on big Pharma uh just to
normalize their hormone levels and
endocrine system they have been fried
emotionally and and I think there's a
reason that this is how happening I
think this is all deliberate I think
this is all a part of their agenda
because when you're sad when you're
pathetic you need someone else to step
into your life and then take control of
it that person stepping is is the
government and that government needs and
relies on those people who are destroyed
essentially by them as well and look at
what's happening in Canada with maid
it's like the opposite version but but
just as dark you know sign up you know
fill out an application take your uh
take your life away I mean and for for
simple reasons like that too it's it's
really uh that that terrifies me you
guys the same thing you guys ever see
the movie Gamer with um what's that
what's that guy's name uh sounds
familiar well Gerard Butler's in it so
basically there's a guy he's like
falsely accused or something and then
you if you you're on death row you can
you're granted freedom if you elect to
be used as an avatar in a game where
game video Gamers can control your body
and so Gerard Butler is in like this
battlefield he's got to kill people
whatever and this kid's controlling him
and he's like okay give me control
you've never seen this no I haven't
either and so who's this oh 10 years ago
and so dry Butler is like give me
control and I'll win and so then the kid
like stops and then Gerard Butler just
goes ape and starts taking everybody out
but then basically the the point of the
story is
they have these uh online games where
you can take some kind of like brain
implant that you like snort or something
and then give up control of your body to
someone for someone to use as an avatar
so there's like people who who go to
this club scene and then people use
their bodies for like weird sex stuff
and then in the end what happens is the
guy who made it all has absolute control
over everyone else who's plugged in so
there's like the scene where he's like
doing this weird movement and all the
guys around him are doing the same thing
like he's puppeteering them that's the
thing about neuralink why I'm like I
would love the uh the idea of being able
to plug your brain and like you're
transported into an actual Skyrim like
you see an experience throwing Fireballs
at a dragon or something but what's
gonna happen is elon's gonna knock on
your door and you're going to be like oh
uh Elon Musk is gonna go turn around go
make me a pizza and you go yes you're
gonna turn around he's gonna go do it
and then you're gonna be sitting there
and gonna go you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna be making the
pizza going why am I making a pizza for
him it feels so good I love doing this
why would it it's like yo when they have
norlink in your brain they're going to
come to you and they're going to say
inject this into your blood they're
gonna say hand your kid over and and
you're gonna basically orgasm when you
do these things you hate they will get
you to do things you hate and it will
feel good thousands of orgasms in your
pod as you're being force-fed bugs uh is
essentially the future that allows you
just sold it to some people out there
exactly
that's literally what they're going to
be doing that's how they're going to be
getting that's how they're going to
destroy Humanity with pleasure so you
know I think it's going to be a mix
though of a 1984 style totalitarian
government with of course a Soma Brave
New World reality that I think is also
going to be prevalent as well and we're
seeing this left and right kind of
dichotomy being pushed back and forth
and this is the kind of lock steps that
are being put into place uh acquiescing
Society to towards towards total slavery
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time